A singular figure. In many regards,
the Inca bearable Plato is often referred to in Nick dafydd app,
founder of the Academy,
the first institution of higher learning in the Western world and widely
considered the single most influential figure in ancient Greek in Western
philosophy, the mythical state is a Plato,
puts him on a unique pedestal to talk only of his achievements and influence on
humanity. You could occupy a video all on its own. Well,
what man was behind this fabled figure of ancient Greek thought because
Plato's life deeps.
So far back into our past little is known about the society in which he lives
much of what we do know comes from secondary or tertiary sources due to the
sheer magnitude of time,
separating modern man from the ancient Greek world that Peter lived in to
understand the context surrounding Plato's life.
It is perhaps better to understands the men who influenced him and subsequently
the men whom he influenced as well as examining the writers of Plato
himself.
One of Plato's countless famed quotes States saw as the men they grow out of
human characters seems particularly applicable when questioning how best to
understand the ancient world. This allowed to Plato,
the freedom to express all of his magnificent ideas in reading between the lines
of what Plato and his contemporaries left behind.
We can piece together a better understanding of who Plato.
The man really was and begin to peel back the layers of mystery surrounding this
legendary figure.
As I mentioned previously,
the two and a half millennia separating us from Plato.
It makes understanding as world exceedingly difficult,
little is known about plate as early life, as the details have been lost time,
but a smattering of facts remain.
We do know that Plato was born into an influential aristocratic Greek family.
Most scholars believe he was born sometime between 429 and 423 BC and
Athens, approximately coinciding with the start of the Peloponnesian war almost
immediately. The line between fact and fiction blurs,
as some scholars of Plato maintained that his father Aristan of colitis was
descended from Kadra as the ancient King of Athens thirty-one Plato's mother
boasted,
the lineage of equal pedigree pre-teens brother and uncle were both members of a
powerful oligarchy called the 30 tyrants that ruled Athens after its collapsed,
following its defeat and the Peloponnesian war,
because Plato comes from such a prestigious family on both sides.
It is widely agreed upon the play to enjoy the privileged youth when compared to
many fellow Athenians and his noble status,
granted him access to learn from the top pedagogues of ancient Greece.
Plato once wrote the most important part of education is proper training in the
nursery and his upbringing exemplifies this philosophy in the truest sense from
a very young age,
Plato was educated by the best thing cause of his era setting in motion,
a lifetime of seeking learning,
and ultimately spreading his education far beyond himself.
It is believed that Plato had two brothers and a sister, all those,
some argues that the brothers may in fact be uncles as Plato's mention of them
in the Republic.
Doesn't specify Arysta Plato's father died during his childhood,
but the circumstances and year of Ernestine's death are unknown.
Plato is not the famous philosopher's birth name.
Artistically he's is the name given to Plato by his parents.
But sometime during his schooling,
the boy called artistically is adopted the Monica Plato shortened derivative
of the Greek word plat on meaning broad.
While some speculates that his nickname was given in reference to his broad
forehead or the breadth of his knowledge.
There are several accounts of Plato's wrestling coach giving him the nickname in
reference to his broad chest and shoulders later excelled in all areas of his
schooling and historical accounts. Describe him as bright, yet modest.
Even outside of the classroom.
Plato was a formidable figure as he wrestled competitively throughout his youth.
Some even claim that he competed at the Estonian games competition on par with
the ancient Olympics held the summer before and after Olympic gears as part of
the four year yet
You don't understand place. It was a philosopher.
We must first understand the other great thinkers too, influenced his beliefs.
[inaudible] do you have had significant influence on Plato's ideas?
When we think of Pythagoras,
the Pythagorean theorem from Euclidean geometry is what first Springs to mind
most secondary school children have that theorem drilled into their brains.
But what we often overlook is that Pythagoras was well-rounded and scholarly in
several areas of study beyond mathematics by fingers is one of the earliest
Greek proponents of the concept of Madame psychosis,
the belief in trans migration of the soul and in particular,
its reincarnation after one dies by Thacker is also asserted that everything is
numbered and the cosmos can be explained through numerical principles.
Both of these concepts aren't discussed at length in the writings of Plato and
most scholars believe Plato was taught them by thangka.
Rian's the disciples of [inaudible] Cicero,
the famous Roman or razor and philosopher went so far as to state.
They say Plato learned all things by finger Rian.
Aside from Plato's shared metaphysical beliefs with Pythagoras Plato was also an
accomplished mathematics teacher.
One of Plato's mathematic students was Euclid's the father of Euclidean
geometry, Euclidean geometry simply refers to the standard mathematics goals,
geometry still trolls in classrooms or around the world. To this day,
Euclid's also influenced the Pythagorean theorem and his geometry and other sign
that plays out learned from Pythagoras and subsequently passed down his
teachings to his students. Assumptions.
Euclid Plato was also influenced by Heraclitus and Paul manatees,
two philosophers who veered away from the Greek tradition of ancient mythology
and instead focused on metaphysics.
Metaphysics is the branch of philosophy that explores the fundamental truths of
reality.
Most commonly the relationship between mind and matter Hereclitis was of the
belief that all things changed continuously as exemplified best.
There is image of a river with ever-changing waters by amenities on the other
hands argued in favor of the changeless being as he has a shortage.
That all is just an illusion.
The contrast in concepts of change and permanence clearly influenced Plato's
writings best showcased and Plato's theory of forms.
In two of Plato's dialogues,
he portrays Paul manatees debating the nature of permanence and questions,
whether both motion and rest are or whether rest is,
but motion is not the most well-known teacher and influencer of Plato is of
course,
Socrates while scholars debate the precise nature of the relationship between
Plato and Socrates.
It is clear that a young place was a devoted follower of Socrates and
interesting tidbit of note is that Plato never wrote of himself in any of his
writings.
And instead Plato speaks through Socrates in nearly everything he wrote since
Socrates was famed for his irony and the Socratic method of dialogue later used
both irony and Socratic dialogue to not only portray Socrates in a realistic
light,
but also as an effective means to communicate whatever subject he was writing
on. Beta would also often portray Socrates's ignorance yet inquisitive on a
particular subject and in the call and response dialectic style that Plato wrote
in, he would juxtapose this ignorant portrayal of Socrates against a students
claiming to be an expert on a given subject in doing this Socrates often ask
leading questions or provided counter-arguments against the points that the
students of Plato were making in these dialogues.
Thus allowing the students who further explain or reboot the proddings of
Socrates, some scholars criticized Plato for this portrayals,
but since Socrates left, no written works behind.
It is impossible to say with certainty,
whether or not Socrates would play the fool or devil's advocates in reality,
as a means to test a student's resolve or whether this was simply a writing
device used by Plato to clearly convey his message while it appears that Plato
was most strongly influenced by Socrates in many facets of his philosophy,
their ideas did diverge on certain subjects.
Aristotle Plato's most famous students writes of these differences.
He suggests that while Socrates's ideas about forms can be realized through
investigating the natural world Plato's forms exist in a realm outside the
typical breadth of human understanding. However,
in some of Plato's writings that include Socrates Plato portrays his teacher
discussing mystery religions and other mystical concepts because Plato's
writing seemingly contradicts.
Aristotle's claims about the main difference between the philosophies of Plato
and Socrates.
It is impossible to know what Socrates really believed in this aspect of
philosophy.
The relationship between Plato and Socrates has been questioned since ancient
times by countless scholars.
But today there are four main schools of thought about Plato's portrayal of his
most influential teacher.
The theory with the most traction in modern times suggests that Plato's writings
evolved over time.
And so that his earlier writings depicted Socrates as Plato really store him and
just Plato aged.
He increasingly projected his own beliefs onto his portrayal of Socrates.
The relationship between Plato and Socrates is so to scholars because no
writings from Socrates himself have ever been discovered.
So our understanding of Socrates comes almost exclusively from the way Plato
portrays Socrates in his writings.
It was about subjects in many areas,
but he always wrote in the same didactic style,
his didactic style was foremost in a call and response format.
And oftentimes a student debates with Socrates in an intellectual dialogue place
or use this method of communications or flesh out his ideas.
So that counter arguments,
rebuttals and details the mind draw an emotional response were all highlighted.
The area Plato devoted the most attention to was metaphysics.
Metaphysics is a broad philosophical umbrella in which the philosopher attempts
to explain the nature of reality and Plato explored many areas within
its vast expanses. His most famous work is the theory of forms and it's,
he attempts to explain reality through the lens in which Plato perceives it,
using Socrates as his mouthpiece,
but lens through which plays out attempts to understand the world is since been
dubbed Platonism.
And it can best be summarized as denial of reality of the material world,
where the world we can perceive as humans is only a surface image or a
copy of the true world. If this sounds somewhat heady or confusing,
you're not alone.
As Plato spent volumes extrapolating his interpretation of the world around him
in every subject imaginable due to its inherent intricacies.
The first appearance of Plato's explanation of his theory of forms first appears
in the FITO.
One of his most notable works in accordance with this theory of forms.
There exists two worlds and obvious worlds of concrete objects,
such as the grounds. We can see you or other humans.
This world is constantly changing due to our perception changing as well.
The second world is purely conceptual. Then in it,
there are unchanging abstract objects that can only be understood through
speculation or theoretical thought.
Other scholars separate this understanding into three worlds.
The first is material objects.
The second is mental images and the third realm consists of the theoretical
forms that Plato advocates for.
If this is still a bit difficult to wrap your head around then fairness for
scholars.
I spent countless hours attempting to simplify Plato's theory of forms into a
brief palatable explanation.
Unfortunately it seems this has not been attainable for the infinite complex
hypothetical situations that arise from this interpretation of the world has
given many of history's greatest thinkers. Pause it, useful analogy for this.
Maybe the theory of forms are a set of universals that present themselves as a
solution to the problems with universals. For example,
when someone says the word blue,
you have a vision in your head of what blue looks like.
Your idea of blue may differ completely from the person who said blue to you,
but you both know what the other person is referring to. Furthermore,
there are countless shades and variations of blue. Say for instance,
the difference between a deep blue ocean and a light blue sky,
these are both blue. Yes, they are quite different,
but saying blue is an umbrella term that encompasses anything within the color
spectrum.
We have deemed blue scholars have interpreted Plato's theory of forms through
innumerable, other analogies and metaphors.
And it seems each generation of thinkers is a fresh iteration of understanding
Plato's theory. We could go on and on in regards to this matter,
but for the sake of brevity, let's just depart from the topic.
If you're still interested, not more about Plato's theory of forms,
there are literally hundreds of scholarly.
Interpretations of Plato's works that are available for free in public libraries
and in scholarly articles, Socrates and Plato, where unlike in that,
they both believed in the mortality of the soul and in the existence of an
afterlife, applying logic to this concept of an afterlife,
Socrates believed it is safe to assume that it must be a before life as well
because the chances of this current life being your first life and nearly
non-existent applying this concept to the idea of wisdom.
Plato writes of Socrates is often claiming he knows nothing.
Plato goes on to explain that Socrates and himself believe that wisdom does not
come from the world around oneself.
And rather it is the results of divine insight.
The remembrance of before one is born,
instead of the intuitive understanding that we commonly hold in which knowledge
is the result of life experience, understanding and study. In fact,
Socrates takes this concepts to the extents of claiming that reality is
unattainable to those who use the earthly senses.
Plato famously has Socrates assert.
He who sees with his eyes is blind as a facetious reaction to those who claim
that only what can be perceived through their five senses is real and true
Socratic irony.
Socrates often explains that he knows nothing and he refutes all the ascertation
Plato students offer while giving no explanation of his own Plato is perhaps
best known for his allegory stories meant to teach a lesson through metaphor.
If you have ever taken a philosophy class,
then you're likely familiar with at least one of these such as the allegory of
the cave. The allegory is frequently associated with the theory of forms.
As an analogy used to explain the theory and this tale of the cave,
a series of prisoners are tied up in a cave and forced to stare at a wall with a
perpetual fire casting,
shadows on the wall for them to see a group of free men display various objects
that cost shadows on the cave wall.
But the prisoners do not see the shadows of the men themselves.
The men also speak to one another, but they never present themselves.
The prisoners because the prisoners cannot see the men,
but can see the shadow of the objects they holds.
And the prisoners can only hear the men's voices, but again, cannot see them.
The prisoners are made to assume that the noises are coming from the objects,
casting shadows on the wall,
rather than the free men who are effectively invisible to the prisoners.
This represents and Socrates's shared philosophy,
but the world cannot be accepted for the way it is to see.
True reason is the only way to understand the world.
The other most popular errand agree is the ring of giant GS.
The ring of giant GS allows the wearer to become invisible at will.
A series of ethical dilemmas is post the wearer of the ring of giant GS.
But the common theme among them is questioning whether an ordinary just person
would still act morally without fear of negative repercussions or gaining a bad
rep.
[Inaudible].
Plato did not date his writing.
So it is impossible to know for certain the chronology of his works.
We also are totally unsure of if Plato traveled to study and unsure as to which
lands, if he did travel, some scholars infer from his writing,
that Plato traveled in Italy and in present day, Libya and Egypt,
but no empirical evidence supports these claims. Similarly,
we can only estimate when Plato founded his school,
the Academy likely around age 40, this school,
and later himself would educate many of ancient Greece's other influential
thinkers that succeeded Platos such as Euclid and Aristotle.
The Academy is largely credited as the first Western institution of higher
learning in the world. And it's set in motion,
a tradition of higher institution learning that persists through modernity in
ancient times,
the average life expectancy was much shorter than today due to the lack of
modern medical knowledge and technology. However,
a few wealthy individuals were said to have lived much longer than we would
expect because of that increased access to the limited healthcare of the time.
Plato was one of these such individuals and most accounts of Plato's life,
recounts him living into his eighties while his exact age of death is disputed.
We can say with reasonable certainty that Plato lived to between 81 and
84 years old,
the defenders of explanation is lacking for how a man with such primitive
medical care out to lift his contemporaries by decades,
best access to better healthcare and sanitation due to his aristocratic status
is likely the culprit 23 centuries after his life ended.
Plato's legacy is undeniable as well as directly influencing the generation of
ancient Greek thinkers immediately succeeding him like Kara startle Plato's
impact on Western society.
And the subsequent generations is in comparable place has been studied by
scholars and enlightened desktops continuously since his death.
Many of his ideas are still hotly contested among philosophers and seekers,
and many of the same lessons. Plato taught his students in the Academy.
I taught in Western institutions of higher learning to this date.
It may seem hyperbolic to claim the Plato is Western humanity,
single most influential thinker,
but from mathematics and metaphysics to religion and ethics Plato's philosophy
has molded the minds of millions in comprehensible lengths of time and trickled
down into nearly all aspects of Western society.
So I really hope you found that video. Interesting.
If you please do hit that thumbs up button below,
don't forget to subscribe and as always.
Thank you for watching.